yes we received apologies from Council
uttam and councilor Watton
sorry
yeah there we go thank you chair um it's
a relatively brief report from us
tonight
um I think reflecting where we are in
terms of the audit cycle so you're 21 22
um Financial year-end order is well
underway
um work on site is progressing well
we're getting through all of the testing
and so on that we need to do and we're
working well with your team as ever we
continue to have
um cooperation and support from them to
get through what we what we need to do
um and you know we are there is nothing
coming out of the work that we've done
today that we need to bring to your
attention as a matter of any urgency
um Our intention to sign off is of
course affected by the infrastructure
accounting issue which is the national
issue that's affecting all local
authorities who have any infrastructure
assets such as roads and so on
um
just to give you an update on where
that's up to really because we've just
been chatting about it here
um the intention is that Parliament will
consider a statutory instrument on the
30th of November which if passed will
then be enacted on Christmas day which
means that if the Christmas Day movie is
not much cup we can all get on with uh
with revising your accounts and um and
and doing the associated audit work
obviously once that statutory instrument
is published and we can all see it and
consider it the council will need to
decide what it means in terms of your
accounts and in terms of accounting
policies and so on then amend the
accounts and then send them through two
or four audits
um we will do that as soon as we we
receive them and hopefully that will
mean we're in a position to sign off
kind of in the in the early spring
really and it's difficult to be
absolutely uh crystal clear on it
because until we all see it and you've
got time to consider it it's very
difficult to know how much work it needs
in order to address it
the second part of this progress report
that we bring just for your general
attention really is a list of reports or
documents that might be useful to you
because you're responsible for the
governance of the council it's not
confined to you as an audit committee
you may find that it's helpful to share
those documents with others and submit
them aware of and there are a couple of
things to bring to your attention uh one
is the first report that's listed in
there which is around the frc's report
on audit quality uh considering all of
the suppliers in the local audit Market
to give you some assurance that the work
that we're doing meets the quality
standards that you would expect and then
the other one which is item three is
around
um changes to the way in which councils
can use flexible Capital receipts
there's nothing in there that you need
to be particularly aware of or concerned
about because the council doesn't
tend to have assets that he wants to
dispose of to other organizations within
its own group but it's important to just
bear in mind that that guidance has been
refreshed you will see in there as well
um the Sip for accounting card for the
next financial year end
um whilst that code has been published
it's a draft document at the moment and
there will be some changes to it arising
from the infrastructure issue so other
than that I wasn't going to say anything
more about the report
um we will of course report back to you
when our audit work is concluding about
the the issues that have come out of the
accounts audit thank you thanks very
much any questions anybody
sorry I didn't catch that last part it
might be boxing day before the chair
replies
okay anybody questions for anybody else
nope
thanks thank you Karen
item six is uh General government
statement which was circulated later on
Mark I believe you're going to do that
okay thanks chair I'm taking this uh
item on behalf of legal and governance
um if you remember Alex Murray back in
July uh presented the draft version of
this annual governance statement
um it according to the accounts and
audit regulations it needs to be
finalized to accompany the final
accounts one once they're approved
um there's been very little update made
to it because it's a statement on 21-2
so you wouldn't expect things to change
but there have been some updates to the
uh at the back end of the report which
covers governance issues going forward
in 2223 so it it's just to advise and
there's a couple of areas one they start
on page 41 of the report uh one in
relation to the medium-term financial
position to the number of developments
and things known over the last few
months to to update the position on that
and also the governance issue around
information governance so both those
areas have been updated just to make
things more more up-to-date and in line
with also the likes of the Strategic
risk register where the update's been
put in there so that's really the the
the change to the uh to the draft
version that was that was brought here
in July
um so basically we'd be looking for the
for the committee to approve the
statement but on the basis it wouldn't
be finalized until the accounts
themselves were were signed off and and
approved
it would eventually then be signed the
governance statement would be signed by
the chief executive and leader before it
went on the council website
Mark any comments or questions
no I think you've got away with that
Mark thank you
item seven is the treasury management
mid-year performance report Frank is it
you Frank fellow
uh yes that's me thanks chair
so this is one of three treasury
management reports that we produce
during the year and this gives the
um performance of the treasury
management the council for the first six
months of the year
so here you'll find updates on debt
levels and interests Etc and Investments
the main headline is obviously the
increase in interest rates so the
council strategy was agreed and budgets
published in February obviously things
have changed quite significantly
in February or since February
um so interest rates I think it says
gone from we said it was going to be the
base rate was going to be an average of
0.56 during the year we're now thinking
it's going to be about four and a half
percent by May
so the council's
cash position has been relatively decent
first six months and we haven't asked to
take out any significant
um borrowing so most of the change from
the budget is on the investment side so
in terms of
the amounts of return we're expected to
get from up to council's investments
from our native Surplus cash we had
that's gone up by about two million
pounds which is reported through the
period six was your monitoring
um
aside from that I think the other main
change is the potential indicators a
change to the
um Prudential codes now requires the
council to produce those indicators on
at least a quarterly basis so we've been
publishing through the
um the bi-monthly budget monitoring so
if you're looking from that's where they
are so they'll be so the
will be in the period six
budget report
I think so
okay thanks very much any questions
about that
anybody
Ross Council Thompson
[Music]
yeah thanks for that
um uh 5.8 on the report talks about we
haven't had any new borrowing this year
um and there's been no debts
restructuring so far but believe that's
that's might be a POS might happen in
the in the near future our debt
restructuring
um do you know anything more about that
and what that would look like
yes so
um we do have
um various uh debt instruments that are
expiring in the next
um 12 months or six months I think
there's the uh we have some Lobos
expiring well to come to two
there's a there's a change in the
interest rates possible in December
so we will have the option if they
change those interest rates to repay the
Lobos in which case we can
um we would need to refinance or
potentially just we might pay that off
cash surpluses or whatever
I think what we will do because of the
change I think the interest rate is
probably now stabilizing we kind of know
where they're going but in the first six
months they were jumping around quite a
bit
um so when the if we get any
opportunities to
um
to refinance or to review our debt I
think we'll look at it and we'll
probably take the decision at that point
based on what what else is happening in
terms of the council's cash flow what
are the rates are available elsewhere so
it would it won't we're not saying that
we will definitely seek to restructure
any debts when they arise but at the
same time we would we're not saying we
wouldn't either
thanks any further questions
no thanks very much thanks Frank thank
you so item eight budget monitoring
report period six
um Dave are you doing that David
mortgage
it's obviously a technical uh
thanks any questions from members
all right
[Music]
thanks Chad um
you you mentioned the level of
contingencies in children and adult
social care services and just what level
um those are at and just broadly I was
particularly thinking of children's
services because you're looking at a
relatively low number of children but a
significant increase on that could it's
difficult to forecast but it quite
significantly affects the what the the
expenditure that you incur and we are
it's very likely to go to a very
difficult winter
um and the effects on on on on families
who may be struggling at the moment um
so
and that's kind of an area that I I was
interested in but really what what do
you deem as the significant risks at
this stage now where we are in terms of
the budget process on the that could
could wildly affect the um the the
outturn for the rest of the year thank
you
yeah it's it's always
um an area which we have to manage
really carefully I mean for instance we
had two placements that were
nearly a million pound for two
placements so they've been tailored down
in terms of negotiation in the contracts
and the needs and they've got a step
down and there was a period two for
period four where that correction was
made so we are potentially dealing with
big costs here that could you know wipe
out any assumptions that we've made the
contingencies that the um that we've
brought about I think it's about a
hundred thousand pound between the
adults continue to see and the
children's contingency there's nothing
at this stage of the budget to suggest
that that isn't within the normal
parameters of what we'd expect to have
at this time of year so there's nothing
being concerned or or raised by the
service areas to say that that's not
going to be any worse or this present
moment in time
foreign
thank you and I mean this
thanks for the report there's an
absolute ton of information in here
um do you mind to ask a few specific
questions where there's a page number
out I'll say that before I ask the
question
um
but that's a general question
um
rather than any page specific one the
school DSG budget am I correct to think
that money comes in will you passport it
out to schools and if that's the case
how are we how do we have an overspend
okay yeah so so that with the government
the government give you the pot of money
from the DSG and then we have the local
formulas to how we hand that out to
schools within there there's various
blocks the primary school box Secondary
School block and then there's a special
educational needs block the the scn
block is is particularly Under Pressure
so the money obviously is the same with
our with our social care budget if a
child comes in with scn needs they get
assessed and then obviously their needs
are tailored within within that needs
requirement so the budget is is is is is
a potential large pressure area for for
the DSG so years ago the council had to
manage that within its own resources
um recently there's been the change in
that in the in the program that the scn
all of those School blocks have to be
about managed within the actual DSG
Grant that's available so that in effect
it protected the council as T and and
this this actual
um there's a deficit now that
accumulates so obviously the grant comes
in spend goes out if there's a shortfall
on that it gets carried over to the
following year so this this dhg deficit
principal position it's a national issue
so many councils have been carrying DSG
deficits for many years now we're not
been particularly effective within
Trafford until the last couple of years
and our size of our deficit isn't
particularly big compared with other
councils but it's been recognized at a
national problem
um the the a couple of years ago the
department for Education said that
councils had to come up in conjunction
with schools for for deficit correction
plan so how are you going to get these
costs down the demands still coming into
the system all the time so it's not an
overnight fix that was recognized in the
Autumn statement last week when they're
putting in about 2.5 billion pound extra
into the school's budget this year
similar figure for the following year so
I think there's some now starting to
realize there's not enough resource in
the system to manage these pressures so
that's the general principle of it thank
you
um
onto page or slide 30. um
there's an identified five million pound
pressure driven by inflationary factors
I think through here there's various
bits of oh and we think we can claw back
some of that here and Claw back some of
that there unless I've missed it I may
have done I may have missed how much all
those clawbacks add up to so how much of
that five and a half million gap is
still to be filled
um the the five and a half million I
mean it's a fluid figure still we're
still looking at an energy with
obviously there was a spike a couple of
months ago the wholesale price of gas
and uh is starting to drop a bit I think
obviously with the mild winter as well
that that's helped
um we've just the the way we we purchase
energy were part of a purchasing
Consortium so they'd still do spot
contracts and if they see an opportunity
that the rates
um had some reasonable price they'll
actually buy so so that the element of
the the five and a half million includes
about 1.3 million I think for it for for
the energy costs
um so in terms of the overall part five
and a half million as I said we were
waiting to see if the government were
going to put some more support on the
table
as the awesome statement they haven't
done that so now we're looking at right
why actually now we got to take the risk
of Reserve we're going to have to draw
down that so that's three that's three
million within our corporate budget we
keep we keep a contingency amount that
we
um so it's it's roughly about two
million pounds so we draw off that
throughout the year for any unknowns
that we haven't budgeted for so we we've
kept probably we've split into two we
said let's let's ring fence a million
pounds of that
specifically to meet this pressure so
that that's that's what that's we've got
we've got about four million out of five
and a half so now we're now looking at
what action we can take to close that
Gap a bit more
um for instance there's money coming
into from the Health Service the the
last mini budget
um they announced 500 million pounds
coming into the system for Hospital
discharge that was the details of that
were announced last week so there's
money coming in to do that we have a
hospital discharge budget ourselves as a
council but the moment we might be
looking at in terms of can we utilize
some of this resource from the national
scheme to free up that resource that
we've got within our own budgets so
these are the things the mitigation that
we're looking at
um the other things that the savings
programs that we brought in plans for
next year can we bring them in so
there's certain activities we are we are
doing the vacancy factor for instance so
this the six the five Millions the gross
figure but you can start seeing the two
chunky figures there for the reserve and
then that's getting down to four and
then the action we're going to take
overall as part of the management
controls
so I couldn't do the maths as you were
speaking so there's five and a half you
start yeah it's five and a half to start
with we've got what numbers did you
identify that we can chalk off that what
I'm after is what's this still
outstanding balance of we don't know how
we're going to find that yeah yeah so
we've got three million in reserve which
will pull off the balance sheet we
didn't really want to touch that one
we're gonna have to do
so I suppose what would what we'd need
to look at what can we reduce the cost
so if you could just give us the number
so there's three million in reserve
so we've got one and a half thank you
which is probably the figure as it
stands at the moment pending any
management action that is standing the
vacancy factors and lots of that thanks
ever so much
um
away from the kind of Revenue budget
looking at the investment and the imb's
work yeah
um we say that we're searching for new
investment opportunities
who is it that helps us do that search
to find your opportunities and how do we
judge their performance as Searchers
please
yeah so the council's got a contract
with CBRE
um who are property advisors
and they presents opportunities to the
council
those opportunities are then
vetted internally ensure that they meet
the Criterium of the approved strategy
and those are then presented to at a
high level to the IMB
and then if the IMB approves them at the
stage one those opportunities will then
um
go on to have further detailed due
diligence put on them
so they would then come back to the
council to be reviewed in terms of the
the due diligence and then a final
opportunity for the MB to review that
work so in terms of performance for CBRE
um we don't currently have I suppose a
performance element related to the
number or the frequency of those
proposals aside from the fact that CBRE
get paid based on whether or not we
proceed with deals
so it's in their interest to bring more
deals forward
and
and then in terms of the quality of the
deals those will be based on how we
decide we would want to proceed with
them so
we would do we would run the numbers so
from a financial point of view whether
it's financially acceptable and then
we'd also look at the risk profile of
the deal so certain deals would have
different risk profiles
so I presume we're in competition with
lots of other councils looking for great
investment opportunities so is it the
council's Judgment that CBRE are the
best searches found in the best deals
are we currently comfortable wise
what I'm exploring
that's something that we will be
um we'll be looking at shortly because
we're look we are cbre's contract is
coming up so we're going to be doing a
procurement process
shortly which where we will be reviewing
um I guess what else is out there in the
market
it's because I think CBR is a contract
was initially signed a while back so
is that that I wasn't involved with that
decision but I actually know they were
the they had the best uh proposals
through that procurement process and
then we'll do another rigorous
procurement process where we see what
other providers in the market have to
say
thank you that's uh really helpful
um
two or three more FMA
on
page 50s this is coming back to Bringing
money in
um and the sums involved aren't great
here but there's um probably forgive me
a degree of irritation in the question
it says that um
Council approved in position of car
parking fees which purely for the reason
of generating Revenue which came up some
political discomfort
but the revenue benefit to support the
budget has been delayed by late
implementation
of said car part fees so is there is
there an explanation of why if Council
takes the brave step to say we'll take
the Flack and and take those charges in
order to protect services that I was
then delayed and therefore the revenue
benefit was delayed
I'm not I'm not sorry I'm not aware of
the the reason for the delay I can I can
find out what uh what that one is sorry
that's on the savings program isn't it
yeah is that the hundred thousand
resident Park if you can find out later
before yeah you can find out what uh the
reason for do you know detail Frank or
not
um
get back to you on that one so that's
that's the 100 000 into
um
and just forgive me okay in the
rag rating on page 56.
um there's a red rated 100 000 pound
saving in digital strategy uh with the
comment in inverted commas
yet to be identified so if you've got a
hundred thousand pound saving planned in
this financial year and we're what six
months through it if we haven't
identified what the saving is
how would we have a hundred thousand
pounds saving yeah yeah the digital
strategies but it's a it's a wider
principle I think
it's it's on the concept that the
introduction of technology and
streamlining processes we will deliver
savings
um
the relationship between that investment
and the delivery of those savings is is
across many principal areas and teams
with it within the council so I suppose
this is the principle with the wider
concept of the strategy that
um is an acceptance that investment in
technology should deliver some savings
we are looking at um a number of
Investments within uh within i t that
looks at trying to streamline the
mechanism and the process of
um completion of forms for instance in
the lives of that so
we've just introduced this this module
and that the team are working within
that across or many service areas within
the council prioritizing those in terms
of which ones will potentially deliver
so I suppose it's it's that time lag
between that investment finding the
program that identifying the priorities
and actually then delivering those so
that that's
that's the reason generally as to why
that saving is it's not a it's not a
specific this is we'll invest in this
technology and it'll save this in this
one area it's across the entire Council
so those programs are still being
developed
um when the intention that that saving
will be delivered
foreign
ly not an expert in this area but in
another life I have served in change
management steering groups and I.T
change steering groups and I don't think
I've seen a well spend a load of money
and we'll work out well make the savings
later so
again outside of this week I'd be really
interested to understand how those
savings are going to be identified yeah
so you can get some more detail on me I
know I'd love that thank you Paul James
and has talked about the digital
strategy at this group before whether
whether we can
and put some more detail on that for you
I'll see I'll see if we can find any
more details what the relationship is
there I'd really appreciate that yeah
last one I know you want more about just
last one please chat
um
all the way down still in the rag rating
down at slide 107. it talks about
a backlogging subject access requests
um and if my memory serves me from late
last night it's getting bigger rather
than smaller
um says that any light that could be
shed on that
I think that's one of the areas that we
can be judged and fine for if we're
naughty yeah um a degree of alarm though
so what page is that one on Slide 107.
that's why it says I'm reading the 107
out of 104 at the top left
okay I can find out some more detail on
that what um
I know from a few years ago the question
what what similar the thing the
principle was that the um Staffing
vacancies within within that data access
team uh was the main reason why there
was a backlog with it but I can I can
find out some more detail on that one
thank you okay
that's it thank you anybody else
councilor Thompson
yeah just going back to the council tax
income and there's been a significant
decrease in a shortfall of four
five one k
because of an increase in single persons
claiming their discount with my rough
calculation that must be around 4
000 click extra claims set about right
do you think
and I I was just wondering
if that's a genuine changing
demographics there are these extra 4 000
single people in Trafford
um how will that affect our calculated
income going forwards and if it's not
then that's a significant challenge
significant number of people to
challenge
extra 4 000 people it seems like a no a
lose-lose situation though if it's true
or if it's if it's false
yeah I did ask this question into the
that of the uh
a lot of the properties that have been
built now are either one or two bedroom
flats and apartments so that that that's
we do challenge you we have a lot of um
third-party company because it's always
one of the easiest things for people to
claim
um inadvertently so we do we do
challenge that on a regular basis and
the pattern is coming through that it is
they are genuinely one and two bedroom
because of the principle the new Bill's
going up so
um it's something not all of the the
principles of this council tax outturn
at the moment we need to reflect that in
the council tax base for next year so
we'll look at for instance the shortfall
in the tax base
that's one of the reasons single person
discount there are other discounts with
within there that causes that shortfall
and obviously that's offset against the
council tax support being lower than we
anticipated when we were saying the
budget so if those two things are
recurrent they'll set each other off
going forward but when we start looking
at the
um for the council tax base
um
for next year's budget in the next
couple of months we'll tighten up on
these figures and see what's required
what's not recurring what can we do
about that and uh we'll we'll adjust
that in the in the tax base for next
year
foreign
[Music]
nine which is the uh audit assurance
report which I think Mark is going to
deal with
thank you
um so yeah just to give you an update
some internal audit work uh we've
completed between July and September
um
I think on page 80
um
section three
um just summarizes the main areas of
work
um we've done with
finalized a number of audit reports
During the period
covering cyber security adult social
care and schools and we've also been
required to sign off a number of uh
Grant claims in the period as well
um section five
lists and and briefly describes uh the
the audits completed and also the the
grant work completed
um you see in terms of the final reports
that have been issued
um opinion levels have either been
um reasonable or in the case of the two
schools there uh the highest opinion we
give substantial
um for those two schools
um there were a couple of other pieces
of work well in progress as well where
we we got to draft stage of the
reporting around payroll and and
Cloverly primary so they they've they've
since been finalized and will report on
those in the next update
um
you see the the bottom of the table uh
the grant certification we've done uh
work in relation to highways funding and
covid-19 testing Trace funding and also
through uh Universal drug treatment
um so we've been required through
governments for there to be internal
audit involvement in in providing
Assurance there that the the Grant's
been used in terms in in line with its
conditions
um
then in terms of other Assurance work
which cover on page top section six
um make reference to a number of areas
that are covered Elsewhere on the agenda
as well around strategic risk register
and the annual governance statement
um also points out right around national
fraud initiative work uh that we've been
preparing for the submission of data for
the for the new exercise that that
data's now recently been submitted
um so I'll provide an update on on work
around the fraud initiative at the next
the next meeting
um
just in terms of responses toward it
work in the period
um still today all the actual
recommendations we've made have been
accepted by management which is pleasing
to see
um in terms of following up previous
audit work uh there's been a number of
uh follow-upord it's during the period
that are listed uh in in section five
the covering cyber security and adult
social care payments and we've also had
updates on a school there's been you
know progress made in each of these
audits but it's acknowledged that
there's still some more work to do in
some of these areas
um and we've come and there's been a
good direction of travel and the
recommendations have all been
implemented all this progress been made
with some of them where for the reviews
where there is still quite a few in
progress or in part we will keep them on
our radar and also include in the next
next internal audit plan so we'll to get
some assurance that that progress
continues to be made
um
just in terms of progress against the
audit plan
um seeing appendix one shows time spent
against various areas in the plan and we
had a target of 30 assignments during
the year
to complete a draft or final stage as at
the end of September we it was the
halfway mark if you like we reached 19
and there have been a few assignments
completed since the end of September so
we are well on track to achieve that
that annual Target
uh I also make brief reference to client
feedback because we do seek that when we
we issue a report
um and I'll give a more detailed
analysis of that in the annual report
um but we've had eight responses
to the reports we've issued up to now
um providing feedback and say I'll
Analyze That in more detail
um for the year-end reporting
um and then finally planned work for
October to December which is is well
underway now
um it says there's an issue issue of a
number of final reports including
payroll council tax home to school
transport so we've actually issued those
as finals in recent weeks so I'll pick
those up in the October to December
update report uh at the next meeting
um and finally progress generally across
the plan is shown in appendix to uh
where you'll see the listing of reports
uh planned and the status of where each
of those those is up to and we'll update
that further in in the next couple of
updates to the committee
um so happy to take any any questions
mark any questions or not
uh thanks chair and um thank you very
much for what it's um I've I've never
done an internal um as an external
auditor and everything to internal audit
but um I've had to um sort out
internally tell audit issue uh points to
raise so it does look in the familiarity
as um is um quite start just on the on
page eight on the implementation of
audit recommendations
um obviously I've got about a third
implemented two-thirds knots and the
different stages what sort of time frame
of those some of those um taken into and
the risk of the ones which are older and
either not started very much or not
implemented at all yeah
um with responses in terms of
implementation there are a number of
audits where it's probably a bit more
straightforward and we get you know for
instance in the last few updates around
schools have been fairly straightforward
to do and they've been implemented
within a few months
um some of these reviews in this report
are quite why wide areas and big big
topics on cyber security
adult social care payments involve a
number of different service areas so
some of those recommendations are quite
developed developmental if you like and
development of systems and they're not
just
fill in that box
um have you done it or not so the ones
except you know there may be over sort
of 6 12 or even in months or even longer
than that
um so we we've tried to give credit to
show yes certain actions have been taken
what we know the service has got all the
further plans that they're working
through
um and also from doing one audits a year
ago there might have been changes in the
environment generally that mean that
yeah they have done some things but
there's still more more to do as a
result
um so I think in each of those areas
we'll include those on on the next audit
plan to yeah for the follow-up
Joseph Thompson thank you thanks for
that on the client feedback is is there
a scope for people managers to
suggest improvements or different ways
of doing things is there a forum to do
that
with what we do at the moment is
um after each report goes out with
there's not we've developed an online
form in the last year so we found
actually I think the response rate's
gone up a little bit on the back of that
so there's some standard questions just
to Mark Us in terms of you know the
quality of the report or
um but what we do as well we do have a
narrative section at the end for any any
comments or feedback I'm generally on
the audit process so there is that
vehicle
um also I believe
um internal audit there will be um a
review of us by sit for as part of a f a
thing that was done every five years an
external assessment and I believe as
part of that there will there'll be more
opportunity as well that's it for will
be asking managers uh for feedback so
that could be another another route but
yeah yeah it can be useful feedback to
to take on improvements yeah
foreign
yeah so this is a a further update
um CLT
um have been I've provided this most of
the risk updates are from sort of the
end of October early November so there
will be over you know if if there have
been major developments saying last week
or two might find that certain things
all all need updating further for the
next update
um just sort of key headlines changes
from compared to the previous update it
gave
um there wasn't a new risk been added uh
risk 7 on page 110 uh and that covers
um impact of number of statutory changes
uh and and and uh reforms talking
particularly around
um social care and education of course
in in the last week or so I've heard
that there's been some delays to the
likes of the um care charges other
reforms around that they're actually
being put back but I think there's an
acknowledgment it's a new risk on there
I think it'll need more work in in
developing that but it was a means of
acknowledging a number of different
areas and things on the horizon for the
council to uh to manage the impact of
um so some description of of that there
in Risk seven
um
also
the cost of living crisis really making
sure that was reflected
in in the Strategic risk register and
and and that's uh shown risque page 111
um to show in terms of the council's
response around or around that of the
impact on residents and and businesses
um and then finally there's um a
decrease in one of the risk scores which
is around business continuity risk 16
covered on page one two five and that's
to acknowledge progress that's been made
over the last year around that
um or acknowledging this further further
work still required
um all the other risks on the register
have been updated uh since since it was
last shared
um chart on page 95 summarizes the the
risk levels
um and also them from 96 you have the
narrative on each of the risks
um will there be a further update for
the final quarter of the year so that
will that will come to the just comes to
the committee in the new year
and also to note on a couple of the risk
areas that we'll we were planning to
have more detail risk updates so cyber
security
um Paul James came last year at the
attention he'll come to probably the
March meeting to give an update on that
and also around information governance
as well we've put that in the audit work
program for an update in March
um covering the various issues around
that
um it's again happy to take any
questions
sorry leave them any questions anybody
Mr Carter
thank you
um using your numbering I'm on your page
110
which is slide 114
um just going back over that last
subject you covered and you said you've
been identified as a new risk 7 because
of changes in
I think he said how the government's
doing things or whatever but and this
may be a subject that we've looked at
before but it it kind of feels like
we're gently rolling faster and faster
towards a cliff Edge and if you scroll
down onto the next page you go over the
cliff and it's 10 million quid
um is the fact that the way in which
social care charges per individual
households are going to be kept
and that we're staring at her
belonging massive on an unaffordable
black hole as a council as a result of
that so that's not a technical term by
the way that's just uh
um my casual observation
um
is that something that we are exploring
and anticipating in sufficient depth at
the moment or do we need
to be looking at that in more detail
I mean I I am aware that there's been
work so this it's been known for a while
um so I know that in terms of various
groups within the council looking at it
I know there's been a delay to that
um I guess that'll come to light
obviously we'll leave the financial
reports and we do and the forecasting we
do uh she's heavily linked to all the
risks on the register like the the
finance one in Risk one
um so I think it's it's an
acknowledgment there's issues there that
were trying to trying to deal with and
not wait until sort of October 25 or
whatever and um
see work being done see how that can be
mitigated
I think it's interesting to return oh
sorry my mother just went I think that
they
the size of the the cost implications on
the cup of the care costs
um that was probably one of the reasons
why the government stored it from the
awesome statement the whole
um social care
um reform which would include the cost
of the Care cap as well as elements
within the uh to stabilize the marketing
for playing a fair price of care
um
there was there was a major concern
within the local Authority
representation that the size and
magnitude of these unknowns were too
much of a risk to carry on with that
official with the original deadline
dates of October uh 23 so obviously
that's one of the things that must have
actually been listened to as part of the
Autumn statement so that's why this is
all we're postponing it
and they've redirected the money that
they were putting in the system to cover
that whether it was sufficient or not
that was a big question back into the
system just to cover the basic operation
of the social care budget so I think the
risk has overwhelmed that's why I've
installed it
thank you that often take stalling as a
reassurance but I'll take that thank you
okay further questions no thanks for
that we'll go on to item 11.
I believe Karen you're taking this out
uh yeah I referenced this report earlier
on actually when I was talking about the
um
reports that were being provided to you
this is the frc's public report on the
findings from their review of audit
quality for the 2021 audit cycle
um this sets out I guess at a fairly
high level really the findings from that
work and provides Assurance to you about
the quality of the work done by your
external auditor
um the review process if you like is is
quite a complex one in so much as there
are parts of the review that are done at
a firm wide level so they they the FRC
satisfy themselves about how firms do
things overall and then they pick a
sample of files which they subject to a
specific and more detailed inspection
um probably worth pointing out that some
of what is in this report talks about
some of the challenges in the market
overall
um around audit and audit quality so the
fact that audit opinions have been
delayed for a few years and so on is
referenced in there and and the FRC
rightly raised concerns about that
um but don't don't really help to um
conclusion about what needs to change or
how
however probably is a a helpful report
to you as I said just to give you the
confirmation around audit quality but
also to give you some comfort around the
depth of the check-in that he's done in
that sense so I suppose the the question
about who audits the audit as well
um I think I think this is this is that
that process really so that's probably
all I was going to say but if members
have got any more detail questions I can
pick them up
thank you chair and um it's really
interesting reading um so
um I mean I've never as an accountant
I've never I've never worked in local
government toys in the private sector
but it is interesting that the the the
the the the the FRC is at least
addressing some of the problems that I
think everyone who's an accountant will
know about
um the the there's the probably the
the the
um Workforce Workforce shortage that
there is in the audit audit audit
industry um but as you said the report
doesn't really actually it just says the
problem is not threatening any any
solutions but no that's just my my
comments thanks
anybody else any comments
no well thanks Karen for that thank you
so we've gone to item uh 12 Council on
it work program
okay the um so the work program there
um
so it includes the agenda for the next
two meetings
um the next one we're expecting what an
update from Star
um from Lorraine Cox
um and also the the work programs are
mended slightly as Karen referred to
earlier with the accounts that will be
now in the uh in the new calendar year
um so I think it says in November still
at the moment there
um so they're the the main points really
in terms of updates on that
okay any queries about that
okay we'll look forward to hearing from
that star again next time
okay now I don't think there's any
urgent business I'm not aware of any
urgent business
urgent business so now we come to the
exclusion resolution it's very unusual
we don't normally have things in part to
but in this case it's a matter because
it involves
um Financial details of businesses so it
helps to go into part two which means
we'll have to leave those people on
their YouTube and the members of the
public who don't have to be present so
we'll close this part of the meeting and
then when we're close down we'll open
again okay thank you